welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is day one and we're gonna learn
the morning routines of billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
every morning i prepare myself for the
day so i listen to some form
of either a spiritual song
or i read some kind of spiritual passage
i do i read something called the bowl of
saki which is written by a
a sufi master or i'll read a daily word
and then i
i meditate and i do a gratitude
um journal and whether i'm doing it
electronically or whether i'm you know
writing in my little journal that i can
i don't carry the journal around
if i'm going to be on longest vacations
because once i left a journal in a hotel
and god only knows what you could sell
that for so i don't do that
but i i keep some form of spiritual
practice
where i remind myself daily
of where i've come from it has said that
you are sitting around with your team
and so forth but you don't like meetings
before 10 a.m
no you like to get eight hours of sleep
and you don't like um
power points explain all that why is
that okay
many so i i like to putter in the
morning i get up early i go to bed early
i get up early i like to putter in the
mornings i like to read the newspaper i
like to have coffee i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have
my kind of puttering time is very
important to me and so that's why i
set my first meeting for 10 o'clock i
like to do my high iq meetings
before lunch like anything that's going
to be really mentally challenging that's
a 10 o'clock meeting
and because by 5 p.m like i can't think
about that today
let's try this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and
and so then on sleep i get eight hours
of sleep i prioritize it unless i'm
traveling in different time zones
sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and
and for me i need adults to sleep i
think better
i have more energy my mood is better all
these things
and think about it as a senior executive
what do you really get
paid to do as a senior executive you get
paid to make a small
number of high quality decisions
your your job is not to make thousands
of decisions every day
so let's say that i slept six hours a
day or let's go really crazy and say i
slept
four hours a day so now i just got four
so-called productive hours back so if i
was going to
you know have say 12 hours of
productive time during any waking day
now all of a sudden i have
12 plus four i have 16 productive hours
so i have 33 percent more
time to make decisions so if i was going
to make you know 100 decisions now i
could make 133 decisions
if i did that arithmetic wrong i'm sorry
and and so you make 133 decisions
is that really worth it if the quality
of those decisions might be lower
because you're tired or grouchy
or any number of things now it's
different if it's a startup company i
mean you know you're really
you know when amazon was 100 people
that's a different story but
but amazon's not a startup company and
all of our senior executives
operate the same way i do they they work
in the future they live in the future
none of the people who report to me
should really be focused on the current
quarter
i always tell people sometimes i get you
know we'll have a good
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working
on a quarter that's gonna reveal itself
in 2021
sometime and that's what you need to be
doing you need to be out
sort of you know two or three years in
advance and
if you are and then why do i need to
make 100 decisions today
if i make like three good decisions a
day that's enough
at what time do you get up normally in
the morning
for me it's usually about seven seven
okay
um but i go to bed late so usually it's
i go to bed around
one a.m or so what i am yeah
and you start day with a real breakfast
or just for the coffee or with the water
you know that also varies a lot um i i
think it's probably true that if you
that having a good breakfast
is is a good idea but um usually i don't
have time for that so
um sometimes uh sometimes it's
it's made for me but um probably half
the time
i don't have any breakfast i had to also
have like coffee or something like that
and a mars bar with it
once more sure well i'm trying to cut
down on the on
on sweet stuff so um
but i think i mean i think i probably
should have like a
an omelet and a coffee or something like
that that seems like probably the right
thing and sometimes i do have that
how long have you been meditating for
actually 42 years
and what got you started the beatles
when the beatles started meditating and
um
they drew attention to it and it was a
uh
curiosity and i thought i would try it
and then um it's changed my life it's uh
the big
the biggest uh influence in whatever
success i've had in life
so can you remember what it was like in
the first few weeks or the first few
months
yeah i remember wrestling around with it
i remember that
uh you know you go into the mantra i
went into the mantra
and the thoughts would come back and it
would
be that back and forth and then as it
got bet
better and better and i got deeper into
it the thoughts would become more
valuable more tantalizing and it was
almost
um you know more of a temptation to
think about those particular thoughts
because i didn't want to lose those
ideas
and then i knew that i had to push those
away and it was
almost difficult and then after a while
i remember then disappearing into it
and that was something the first
benefits were
that ability to have the quietness the
tranquility
um the ability to get energy from it
rather than sleep it would provide me
more energy than sleeping
those kinds of benefits but then it went
on
um to develop an
ongoing equanimity that that
centeredness
that ability to go above myself
and my circumstances and to look down at
them
from a higher level with a clarity and
an objectivity
and then it started to bring out my
subconscious
and my creativity because
subsequently i've studied neuroscience
i've been very interested in that
and i've learned that there's a part of
our brain
in the neocortex which is where
imagination exists
which is where creativity exists and it
opened me to that
i experienced it i didn't understand
what was happening at the time but it
provided those things as time went on
what is your morning routine like what
do you do when you first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not i
still you know i read a physical paper
every single morning
which one i read the wall street journal
every morning i read the new york times
online
and you know i still i'm very particular
about
having my tea it's very english you know
i grew up in india
so having my tea and i'm vegetarian so i
need to get my protein so i always have
an omelette in the morning
with toast tea and read my paper
so i do that every morning what time do
you wake up uh 6 30 to 7
so that's when i do it do you exercise
in the morning
now later in the day sometimes uh you
know if i get a chance but always in the
evening i wish i could do it in the
morning i'm not a
morning person so i need my time with my
paper and tea to wake up and
kind of get going i want to know the
very first thing you do you get out of
the bed
you go to the bathroom oh i don't know
the first thing i do is look at my phone
oh you look at the phone first okay
that's interesting
yeah i do that too i i look at facebook
right
to see to see what's going on in the
world right right
and i and i check uh my messages i look
at messenger and whatsapp
and how long how many minutes would you
say you spent you know it depends on
what's going on in the world
on a good calm day right um uh it'll
probably be no more than a few minutes
right it's actually a pretty sad
situation to be honest because i i
have contacts right i mean i can't see
that well right now
and before i put my contacts in i often
go look um to see what's going on on
facebook too
but i'm very near-sighted so i'm like
yeah i i was never a morning person
uh max is definitely turning me into a
morning person
max um is like a pterodactyl it's like i
didn't know a human could make those
noises
right and then do you take a shower or
you're gonna you work out first
the better strategy is to work out and
then you shower i think um
not barack obama he likes to shower and
then work out
a shave and work out which i found to be
very odd
that doesn't make any sense doesn't make
any sense write my goals down first
thing in the day i've been doing this
for 30 years now
writing down impossible goals to achieve
things that like oh my god what would
cause me to get up today
early what would cause me to want to
make that extra phone call
what would it take what would i what
would need to propel me or
inspire me so much that i'm like i'm
willing to do all this hard stuff
that maybe i haven't been doing
and could be possibly keeping me from
getting
the life i deserve in this case the life
you deserve
i still do this today wake up in the
morning write my goals down first thing
i do is write my goals down
these are big goals unachievable goals
second thing i do is write down my quote
of the day what am i living by today
that's somebody else's quote well it
could be but it's really my quote
what is the point what am i authoring in
my life
uh who do i want to be here
she's going to have to write her own
goals down she's going to have to come
up with her own quotes
she's going to have to decide for
herself what she wants to do how she
wants to live
same thing for all of us it's a
beautiful thing about this planet we get
to decide
and do whatever we want to do
or as little
as we want to do problem with the little
part is
if you're capable of doing more than
you're doing and you're not
probably not going to feel good about
yourself i know i didn't
hated myself hated myself
when i knew i could achieve more and i
wasn't
i think this is why people watch sports
see the great pass great catch great
block great tackle great breakout
tackle a great dunk
whatever the shot is right it's like wow
man that person did something that
that is full potential and we're shocked
by it
but in reality
in reality it's probably because we know
we all have that in us
i'll bet you got more in you than you're
using right now
so try this try this simple wake up
early just try it for a couple three
days three or four five days see what it
feels like
try for one day that's all you got
didn't you
and then two break your goals down
unachievable goals you want to be a
millionaire billionaire trillionaire
good write it down want a helicopter you
want a plane
five or ten goals that you want to
achieve or maybe more and then tomorrow
when you wake up tomorrow
do it again see which ones pop up
tomorrow now this is what i do a little
trick
i do in the morning and i do before i go
to sleep at night first thing i do when
i wake up
it's more important than your goals
first thing i do when i wake up
last thing i do before i go to sleep at
night and i'll throw one little trick in
that's how powerful it is anytime i'm
disappointed anytime i'm discouraged
anytime i'm down anytime i lose i write
my goals down again
when i get up early i feel better i just
feel better it just
feels good i beat the sun
up man i i gotta
yay man what's up what's up what's up
man what's up say man what's up what's
up with you
hey y'all
the balloons can't fly
if you're sick of tv if you're sick of
youtube
if you're sick of having your time
consumed man by stuff that
cannot in any way shape or form improve
the quality of your life
i'm talking politics i'm talking money
advice
online what you doing man i don't need
all that man
okay friends you're hanging out with
drinking on fridays look i'm gonna
encourage everybody this weekend friday
saturday sunday go the next three days
without freaking boozing it up
without going out to the clubs without
spending money on strippers or
pornography or wasting time whatever it
is you're doing man
let's get your money right your career
right your finances right
so you can have the life you deserve
you've asked me
over and over and over again hey what is
your daily ritual
what is your ritual how do you start
your day what do you how do you live
your day what's your
like thing the thing what's the thing
man
like like if you want to know what my
thing is you in the right place
today i want to talk to you about daily
ritual
what is your daily ritual first i want
to admit to you
i am not every day doing my ritual
i am a flawed human being
yes i am not perfect
but i'm good all i got to do is win
most of the time now i do know this
first confession is i'm not perfect
second confession is this okay
i'm better i i'm happier
i have more energy i have more
confidence
i get more done when i have a ritual
okay
when i'm doing my perfect ritual i use
this daytimer okay this is a daytimer i
actually created for me
many of you out there thousands and
thousands of people have the planner
it's a 10x planner
and it's basically a combination of
journal i've journaled since i was
probably i don't know
25 i started journaling in a treatment
center
what's wrong with me problem is i was
journaling the wrong stuff
i was journaling about my past rather
than what do i want to create going
forward
so those of you out there journaling you
know i mean
you can only write about your mommy and
daddy so many times
when i was a little boy my daddy spanked
me too hard
some of you like another guy's like when
i was a little boy my daddy never
spanked me
two people had different experiences and
they're spending time in the past
regardless of what happened to you you
know what i made a decision
my past is not what i'm gonna have my
attention on when i when i wake up in
the morning the first thing i do is wake
up to this thing
first thing i do is i'm on the right
side first thing every day when i'm
running my day when i'm in control of my
day
when i'm having my best days i wake up
regardless how i feel and the first
thing i do
before i roll out of bed is write my
goals down okay now when i'm talking
about writing my goals down right here
i'm talking about journaling my future
not
reporting my past now robert's on
was on with me what's up robert sislow
isn't it
okay you can call in i want you to know
i want to know man what do you want to
know about daily rituals this is a
perfect day for me
i wake up before the sun rises i look up
i say i beat the sun
i'm a son of a gun i beat the son son of
a gun okay i beat the sun
call me a son of a [ __ ] i beat the sun
okay and then what i do is i roll over
and i write my goals down now you might
ask what are some of your goals i don't
know whatever i'm thinking about
four billion dollars in real estate okay
average 20 return that's what i just
wrote down
i'm writing as though i'm writing i'm
just starting fresh today okay
i've sold 10 million books plus
i haven't done that yet 10 million
okay tv show tv show
national network and it goes global
okay i'm just jotting this down right
now okay excited about my marriage
excited about my marriage that's a big
thing man
you get that done money can't buy an
exciting marriage you can't buy that
buddy
okay no matter no matter no no amount of
money in the world
can make my kids freaking
love me always love me all right
i don't know so i could go on and on
right that's what i would start the day
with it's going to be about i don't know
four or five
minutes maybe max okay then what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna probably get up and
go urinate
i'm gonna go work out right after that
then i'm gonna have a workout and i'm
gonna get on that ritual man i'm gonna
work out i'm gonna come back i'm a
shower
i'm gonna hop in my grab something to
eat hop in my car
listen to some freaking jamming music on
the way to work
every day i'm gonna do the jam and music
find that music
that gets me lit up not that old redneck
music y'all been listening to to get you
all sad
she left me in the saloon at wednesday
night
so robert what is your ritual dude do
you have one i do actually
man well the last three weeks i actually
upgraded the ritual and now i get up at
like 5
30 yeah and i go deuce a little bit of
crossfit in the morning
and then i take a shower and then i come
into work
i've actually started writing an article
every morning and then
i'll listen to some see you and then i'm
ready for the day
yeah get a little bit of breakfast see
you as well cardone university listen to
some cardone university so
you listen to it or you watch it i watch
it he watches it on his computer okay or
from your phone
the computer okay so so this is what
he's doing every day he's waking up he's
writing an article by the time seven
o'clock hits
i guarantee you robert's thinking i beat
the sun up are you beating the sun up
yeah
he writes his goals down mm-hmm how many
segments to see you you do
about six six segments of cardone
university takes about 18 minutes
literally in an hour and a half robert
sislow will accomplish
more in an hour and a half than most
people do all day yeah so what happens
is
he becomes more confident by the time he
hits the office he's like he's already
got a jump start on the rest of the
world
so you guys are waiting until you get to
work to get warmed up like what am i
going to do today
goals i'm going to write my goals down
first thing i wake up in the morning
every day i'm going to do it before i go
to sleep at night again that's how
important it is i'm going to write my
quote of the day
what quote am i going to live by today
by the way i don't need to go to
instagram
to come up with my own quote okay today
my quote was this
i'm helping people today and every day
okay so i write a quote that i want to
live by and then what are my targets who
are my targets today
before i get to the office i want to
know what my targets are today i have a
show
today i want to get two workouts in
today i got this thing this
this special meeting this afternoon
can't tell you about
special special meeting that i got so
these are physical things that i can
actually
actually accomplish i like the targets
yeah i do write my targets down
and look i want to check these bad boys
off okay
and tough targets i want some tough
targets some tough people to call today
because again what am i trying to do
with a daily ritual let me read you the
the definition of a ritual why do you
want one
ritual a sequence of activities rituals
do not have to be putting a cl
a clan mask on and and
and starting a fire on a friday night
out in the hood
you know what i'm saying that doesn't
have to be a ritual ritual does not have
to be using drugs
all the time everybody's got habits in
ritual sequence of activities
i think when people say ritual they
think yeah the catholic church
some satanic exactly i didn't mean i
don't mean catholics or satanics
you know what i mean something you do
every day dog don't have to be it don't
have to be with a mask
you could wear a mask i mean most people
are wearing a mask
you know what i mean you guys got a mask
on you're not being you
look if you're not being successful
you're not being you are you wearing a
mask i got dads on the phone chris on
the phone jaylin on the phone nayrock on
the phone
ritual sequence of activities involving
gestures
words and objects performed in a
sequestered place
and performed according to a set
sequence let me tell you where my church
is people like you go to church man
every day bruh every day my world
is my church you understand it's called
the church of cardone
it's called the coc the church of
cardone
i wake up i'm in church i don't need to
go to some temple man
okay this morning i woke up and i did
this i wrote my goals down
kissed my wife went to work out
worked out i got 25 minutes working out
i just go to the gym man i don't exactly
know what i'm gonna do
sometimes i do a sequence of events
exercises and then sometimes i make
mix it up so my body right now i don't
need to mix it up because i haven't been
going down there enough
okay i go slap the dummy in the face he
reminds me he's down there i can punch
him in the face overnight there he is
dude
he reminds me don't be that guy again i
come back i get a little bit of reading
done
i eat i shower i get in my car i listen
to jay-z on the way over here this
morning rip holy grail
come to my office man we do a sales
meeting every morning so by 906
every day i have created the same exact
sequence of events why would you want to
do that
why because in a world that
is filled with unknown and arbitraries
and crazy stuff going on
at least i can bring some normality
control prediction and control
to my own life that's why i would tell
you to have a daily ritual
that's why i would tell you to use a 10x
planner that's why robert is using this
every day
because he doesn't know how to sell but
he can be taught how to sell
if he goes back to cardone university
every day what's happened for your
income robert sislow the video
genius dude i mean i mean i'm making six
figures now
he walked i was making how big how big a
deal did you walk into my office just
for me
just now is 144 000. okay now before you
worked here were you ever
no doing 140 thousand dude i was trying
to make eight hundred dollars for two
weeks worth it's not a sales this guy's
not a salesman i can teach anybody how
to sell folks
but you got to do the work okay you got
to be reading the right things
you guys that are looking at bobby over
here and then john over here you got to
pick somebody y'all got to pick somebody
pick a coach you don't need six coaches
you need to pick a coach
okay let's take a caller how much time i
got i got i got
two talk to me from jersey bro
yes yes do you listen to me do you have
thank you for being on the show do you
have a daily ritual
oh yes of course i do what tell me what
is it man
well first of all thank you so much uh
you know for having me on the show
well until last six months i didn't have
now i do i initially started my day by
listening to your videos
on cardone university write down my
goals
work out a little bit do an article
or or you know write some quotes on
whatsapp so i have a group of
winners club i created i write a
motivational quote in the morning
leave a motivational video to pump
everybody up and my goal is to help 10
million people
similar to your goals maybe a little
tiny yeah yeah yeah yeah
10 million that's a lot of people buddy
that's that's an awesome goal where you
you're in new jersey but where's the
accent from
uh basically i'm born involved in india
i'm actually
traveling i'm just in uh we gotta we
gotta you're huge
i love the indian people man indian
people love me man they love me
that's like india jamaican no india
indian people love me man it is indian
jamaican i sound more jamaican or indian
to you
it starts indian and then it goes
jamaican hey hey
do you have a question yeah yeah i i do
actually um look i try and stick to the
ritual uh ritual
and uh try to follow this every single
day
but but the consistency you know it
actually
is not there sometime i i you know so
what do i need to do to stay motivated
and
you know continue to follow the ritual
dude
first of all i would tell you it's a
great question i get asked all the time
you know do three day three to five day
spurts
okay i do spurts like i'm working out
right now i'm gonna get two workouts i'm
trying to get back on my workout how do
i
how do i get the discipline of the
workouts what i do is i take
short runways only for short periods of
time i'm like okay between now and
monday
i'm gonna use my planner twice a day and
every time i'm disappointed
okay i'm gonna do this for a religion
for the next three days i don't wait for
next week to do stuff i do it right now
i do short spurts
okay i'm gonna work out twice a day for
the next three days i know i can do that
man i'm not gonna do any candy no bread
nothing for three days i'm gonna build
disciplines for three days
and then i'm gonna wake up monday and
say dude i got something going here my
goal is to get you focused on your
career
your finances mm-hmm what else your job
your job your money well you said
finances money my money
your head what you gonna do this weekend
what you guys gonna do this weekend i
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna spend
the next three days getting my
discipline back in
because it wanders off right like i want
to get my discipline back in why do i
want a daily ritual that's what we're
talking about today everybody's asking
me what do you do for a daily ritual
here's my day okay
i grab my day timer and what i do is i
write down my goals in the morning i
then
set my quote what's my quote what's the
quote i'm gonna live by today today my
quote is
i'm gonna help people i don't know today
okay i'm gonna reach out to somebody i
don't know
they can't give me anything they can't
help me and i'm going to help them okay
why would i do that because they do help
me when i help other people
then i'm going to sit down and write
down my targets what targets do i have
today that i want to accomplish
need to accomplish i have three big
meetings i got to get done today a
cardone zone i got to get done today
we're repricing all our merchandise
getting ready for the holidays for a big
freaking super sale that we're already
starting to give to some of you right
now
at the end of the day what are my
successes there's a column right here
says successes
okay i need to take a minute hey man how
did i win where did i win what was i
successful at right now i got one
workout in
i got three meetings done okay i've
gotten two shows in the can
right what am i doing to win like if you
don't pay attention to what you win at
you're not gonna
keep winning and then i'm gonna write my
goals down before i go to sleep tonight
i'm gonna try to get to sleep by nine if
my wife doesn't keep me up which
she does sometimes okay and then on the
left side of the page
i have my day laid out as to who i got
to see any appointments that i have to
make any appointments i have to get to
they'll be laid out on the left side of
the page this is part journal
part schedule it's like those old
planners that people used to use
you need one folks okay you need one i
don't care if you're gonna do it on on a
legal pad
like if i if i leave my day timer
somewhere i'm grabbing something
grab something anything man i'll be like
what are my goals today
i'm gonna grab something to start my day
with where i'm going
so i don't spend any time on where i've
been i talk about this in
in the book be obsessed or be average
feed the beast that's
what i'm doing i'm feeding the beast and
i'm starving
my fears okay i'm not focused on what
happened
but what i want to make happen chris
from utah
chris what's up
what's going on not much grant how are
you doing today good sir how you doing
i'm doing really good best day in my
life man i love that man what's making
it so good
i i'm in control buddy you know i i
won't accept anything less than the best
for me and mine enough but anybody tries
to cut me short i'm cutting them out
man that's awesome man hey let me ask
you what kind of schedule are you doing
are you doing a daily ritual do you have
one
yes i do i wake up every morning at 5am
first thing i do is i time the full
bottle of water so i get my blocking
cooling
i've been doing that i forgot i've been
doing that every morning dude that's one
of the first things i do when i'm doing
my quotes i'm doing a
a big giant bring me my bottle okay i'm
going to get 10x made on these by the
way
okay look look i'm doing this is my i'm
on my second one right now i'm trying to
slam
go ahead go ahead yeah and then uh you
know i go straight into some yoga and
meditation i get the stretch on and i i
set out my manifestations and
affirmations for the day that i'm going
to make it the best i can
do better than yesterday and then uh my
next two steps after that is i just put
a post a video
uh motivational and challenge people you
know so i share some inspirational
thoughts and i challenge them to do
something for themselves
dude that's awesome man that's awesome
chris do you have a question i
appreciate you uh you know being a good
example for
having a daily ritual oh yeah
actually you know uh one question i
guess i could ask you is what
what is it um what is it that
helps you step up over every obstacle
that you got i mean i know that you got
i mean
and you play in the game at a higher
level you gotta have some pretty big
obstacles what is it that
that you say or do like a mantra that
you have that you just drop right on
your
it just smashes them instantly yeah well
well man look it's a great question by
the way he makes a good point you're
everybody's going to have obstacles
barriers and
you know doubts you're going to have
doubts you start playing a bigger game a
bigger field you go from college
football to nfl man i guarantee you
dude that's some big dudes over there
you know
i go play basketball with john john
john's in the show today john's a great
basketball player
i go to try to take a run into running
the nets on him i'm gonna be like oh
john john's a big dude man
john's strong so how do you overcome
that man you got it one you got to get
in the game you got to get your head
right folks
you got to be committed to the game you
got to be obsessed with the game
mm-hmm okay i'm not obsessed with being
beat i'm obsessed with being in the game
so i just know this i know today if i
can keep showing up with some discipline
every day
another reason for their daily ritual
another reason to rebuild your
confidence
you know when i was 25 years old man i
was broke man and the guy says you ain't
broke son
unless you think you are. and i'm like
dude i'm broke man
i'm broke and he's like you ain't broke
son unless you think you are
and i'm like yo dude i'm broke man and
he's like
i'm gonna say it one more time you ain't
broke son
unless you think you are and he walked
away
i'm like he got the guy never explained
what he meant
see but i was open i was open i was
finally starting to open up the data
to content to information i was starting
to people starting to show up in my life
dropping little nuggets nuggets one guy
says
you can't change if you don't change
that was sick i was like what i know it
doesn't seem like anything once you've
changed oh it makes sense
but i was like dude that's big i can't
change if i don't change man you know
hey man you are you are a summation of
the three or four or five people that
are around you i'm like dude i don't
even need to go outside my house to meet
five people i got five voices in my head
i got the granted i want to be a great
grant
i'm a loser grant i'm a broke grant
i'm a little grant yeah i'm a fake grant
that was the five grants that i was
living with if i'm the summation of the
five people man i got five i got voices
going how many of you hear voices y'all
hear voices yeah
you can't do this that's not a worthy
goal
you'll never make it it's another thing
you're gonna quit on it's like who's
talking
like man who is this man who is that
okay people like man you are the
summation of the five people i'm like oh
my god i got to handle what's going on
in my head man
you know you got you guys the way to
handle what's on in your head i mean if
you want the permanent solution to
handling what's going on in your mind
i have it i'm not going to discuss it
here but i do have it okay when you're
ready for that you reach out to me
until then what you need to do is you
need to starve
the fear and feed the beast how do you
feed the beast
do you jam your time up jam your time up
why do you want a daily ritual why do
you want to schedule
why do you want to determine when you
wake up and when you go to sleep because
you want to take
your hours and you want to jam them with
so much activity
that you can't get in trouble okay
because i guarantee you
when you've gotten in trouble in your
life before you got in trouble
there was too much time available to you
every time you have fell
off every time i have ever fallen off in
my life
is because i allowed too much time the
more time you have
the more time you have to screw up yep
jaylen
from indy one of my favorite cities in
the world
with so much activity come on jay lynn
jay lynn let's talk some colts
john you need to be my my nfl guy
through the season
give me updates i need to know who's
winning all right okay
jaylen what's going on what's up brad
how are you
good man i'm doing great brother
um i want to talk to you about um how
can i increase my skills
in sales i've been reading your book
right now i'm reading selling be sold
again
i read it like two weeks ago and i'm
ingesting it again
and what what can i do to get better
because
i'm i'm coming to work for you in
december
you're not coming to work for me bro
until you on cardone u
yeah all right so get on card on you
yeah
dude you got you got to escalate the
training now all right
reading the books one thing watching a
guy deliver watching visually
listening okay and testing is a is a
different level
you i'ma tell everybody out there i
don't care if you think you're a visual
or not you learn at 50 times the rate
when you study somebody visually
literally i could turn off the volume
robert sislow
could turn off the volume at cardone u
and just watch me deliver three minutes
if he would watch enough of that over
and over he would start picking up
levels of confidence and certainty
that i deliver at that i could not
deliver out when i was 25 years old
and the reason i couldn't the reason i
couldn't deliver it at 25
years old was i had not studied anybody
that delivered with confidence and
certainty
so so that's what you you got you have
to get
your visual you collect content
visually can you imagine driving a car
without like seeing anything
no you couldn't do it well google can do
it
you know because they programmed
everything but but
you you need to be able to see the
environment right
so until you develop that programming
like like i can literally i can hear
robert working a deal for my office and
know what's going wrong with it
i i've programmed enough now to hear
when things are going wrong
not that anything ever goes wrong with
robert yeah okay
so bro look you gotta number one you
gotta commit to the game you gotta then
become obsessed with the game i'm like
immerse yourself in the game right
yeah become the octopus you know you're
in the ocean you know you don't you
don't go swimming
you live underwater right
you ever wonder how they breathe like
that underwater man
immersion yeah
so man if you want to work for me you
guys that want to come work for me
look you better get ready you better you
better get do your boot camp before you
get here
don't don't come here and do it get it
done don't come here and think
oh great uncle g's going to teach me how
to be a man
that you need to bring you need to man
up before you get here you need to bring
your discipline here
you need to get here early you need to
stay late you need to be doing that at
the job you're at right now that job you
hate right now
okay you hate it because you hate your
life
i'm just keeping it real that job is a
reflection
of you of you not liking what you do man
if you were beating the sun up
writing your goals down you knew you
were going gonna use that job at home
depot just to
pop you to the next thing okay if you're
writing your quotes down every day
living a life that's positive going to
the church
of your choice every day
man there's no way man god's not gonna
look at me later and say but what
religion
were you god's gonna say dude
bro you threw down pretty hard there for
80 years man
i like that about you man you a throw
down dude
now you did a lot of cussing and there
was a lot of women early on
huh but but you know what yeah
pretty good job you did there you did
good come on in man come on in we're
going to party how about some
shots christopher
what christopher how about some kristoff
what is that would it be called kristoff
a big call
it'd be called how about some god all
right
okay let's talk to nayrock from jersey
appreciate everybody watching the show
today by the way we do this show every
every friday 12 p.m eastern standard
time
appreciate your comments your questions
go ahead sir
yes what's going on what's going on
j-rock
nay rock j-rock is it i want to say that
yeah nick rock i want to say that you
are a blessing
to the industry to the
and i wrote a little thing here for you
it says
greg cardone is the motivation
to domination in this nation
because every time i wake up in the
morning
and i thank god that i'm still alive
and that i'm a single father and i have
two beautiful children which i raised by
myself
and i still have a company called
mayrock employment
assisting service that helps people find
jobs
i'm still singing my little rap here and
there at nairo
productions
and i said i think a video too to your
industry
the guy's listening to himself now i
just realized why he's
yeah don't turn your damn radio off man
you don't need to hear yourself now some
guy just told me grant
no grant chad newman says no grant
repent
the kingdom of god is at hand i don't
even know what that means man what does
that mean is that supposed to scare me
or something
sounds i'm scared i'm a little concerned
no grant repent the kingdom of god is
hand dude i am having a personal
relationship with god you're waiting to
have one
okay i'm just saying i don't need to
wait till i die bro
28 years old i'm all connect huh i never
heard that one that was good
i'm all connected into it right now man
i don't need to wait plugged in okay
i don't need to repent nothing i ain't
repenting nothing dawg
i am who i am man i'm doing great i'm
doing great i am the judge
if i can't pass my own test i know i
can't pass this
right i ain't wait i don't need to wait
man i need to do it now man i need to do
it for me i don't need to do it for my
kids
i don't need to do it for the priest i
don't need to do it for my wife or my
mama i need to do it for me who am i
what kind of man am i
who's showing up every day not yesterday
not tomorrow
today who's showing up right here today
man in this next 20 minutes
who's here like who's here man who's
showing up who's got the juice who's
throwing down
what are ethics to you i don't know what
they are to you i know what they are to
me i need to deliver i need to bring it
every day okay
i need to deliver these shows every day
not for you but for me
so that's what we do in this studio i
needed to build this studio i'm not
getting paid to do this
okay but i am i'm paying myself
i have the potential if you have the
potential
it is my belief that is unethical for
you to live
one moment not delivering to that
potential
that's why i wrote these books these
books aren't about i make a dollar 37 on
a book
okay this book we make i don't know if
we sell the book for a dollar 49 how
much can i make
but i know this i can reach people i can
change people's minds i can change their
day i can make friends with people we
don't know
we translate this to 38 languages so i
can meet
friends around the world man god's gonna
be like dude you reached out man
why'd you take so long son now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet
you can get it for free in the first
line of the description below and if
you're enjoying this billionaire mindset
series give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
if you want to change your life change
your outcomes it starts with you
changing your consistent morning routine
you have to figure out what the best
morning routine looks like for you
and that can come from trying on
different people's hats and their
schedules
but you have to have something everybody
has something nobody just wakes up
and then hopes that amazing things
happen not people who are successful
a lot of people wake up like that though
a lot of people do wake up most people
wake up and hope something
happens to them hopes they win the
lottery hopes to get the promotion
hope some big customer calls them right
we're just living in a land of i hope
something big happens to me but i don't
believe it's going to
as opposed to demanding excellence from
yourself
every day and it begins with your
morning routine so how can you do it i'm
going to give you a three-step process
that i think will help
step number one is figure out what makes
you sore so i said this is the most
important part of my morning routine
what makes you come alive and sore
what makes you feel like the work that
you do matters and you have to show up
today so for me
i have to think of a message every day i
think about you guys every day
i i wake up i'm here in my toronto condo
it's hard to imagine that 300 million
people have seen my videos and
that that number doesn't make any sense
right and so it's easy just to wake up
and just continue to live my life me
my dogs my wife and my condo and and
just another
okay day right i have to remind myself
that the work
that i do matters i think of a message
and then i share it and i take out my
phone
and i post something to instagram
typically right and that sets me up that
reminds me that what i do
matters is meaningful i need to demand
excellence for myself
what is it for you maybe it's creating a
piece of content maybe it's making a
video
maybe it's watching a video maybe that
maybe this is part of your morning
routine thank you
and it helps you soar right maybe it's
doing a good deed maybe it's meditation
or prayer or walking the dog or playing
in the
in the sun like whatever it is what
makes you come alive you have felt it
before
you have felt it before you've had
moments in your life where you were bold
confident unstoppable powerful where you
felt like you could take on the world
right
well you felt like your crazy ideas were
possible you felt that before
i know you have the problem is the
problem is
it's not consistent you're not
consistently feeling that way
and so you need to reverse engineer
yourself before you worry about taking
on other people's
routines and ideas which are definitely
helpful reverse
engineer yourself to figure out when in
your life did you feel the most
bold confident powerful alive and what
led to that happening
what led to that happening and then put
that into your morning routine
demand it from yourself every day right
so it could be reading it could be
watching video all the things i talked
about
it doesn't matter you felt it before
reverse engineer what that thing was
and then put it into your morning
routine because if you woke up
and you did the thing that made you sore
that made you feel bold unstoppable
powerful confident every single day
holy cow get ready for a massive change
in what your life looks like over the
next year
step number two is ask the high
performance coach question so again i'm
going through all of this stuff with
brendan
i'm going through all this and in my
favorite question
was the one i read if i was a high
performance coach is what you should ask
every day i like this
if i was a high performance coach
looking at my life from a high level i
would tell myself to remember that
because it's so easy why i love this is
it's so easy to look at other people's
lives and say what needs to be fixed
right
you can look at your spouse your friends
your team your parents
your siblings you know your high school
mates whatever you can look at other
people and say
that needs to be fixed you got to go off
and do this right you you become the
high performance coach
for other people and what i love about
this is that you're looking at your own
life
today as a high performance coach what
would you tell yourself
and then they have one at the end of the
day uh if i was my own high performance
coach i would tell myself this statement
about today
so of all the things on here it's a
great format i like that
the best since i would challenge you for
the next 30 days to ask yourself
that simple question if you were
a high performance coach looking at your
life from a high level you would tell
yourself to remember that
what and then step number three would be
which three people can you model their
routine so
brendan you know he's got his and i'm
i'm modeling this for at least 30 days
i've added you know john assaraf a
friend of the channel been on a couple
times
uh talks about writing down your goals
every day
and then and then touching them right so
i'll write down some goals
and then i and then i write them every
day now and i'm touching them
right that's what he does great again
you got to see what's going to work for
you
maybe i do that for 30 days and stop
maybe maybe it's what i do for the rest
of my life i don't know you won't know
until you do it
consistently enough so pick three people
who you like pick three people who you
respect who you look up to say this is
the kind of person that
i want to learn from and then go
investigate how they start their day
and then and then try on some of it
right you might love the rock
and he works out for four hours a day
you may not be able to do that but you
can work out for an hour a day
right because maybe you're doing nothing
every day
so it's a good starting point like just
get to the gym and start working out
every day right so pick three people who
you love look up to respect
admire and then go research what are
their morning routines and how
can you apply one thing from each of
them to see if it works for you
too many people think that the secret to
success is just waking up an hour
earlier
if you weren't productive with the 16
hours that you
are awake what makes you think that by
adding a 17th hour when you are more
tired is actually gonna make a
difference
the problem is that you're losing too
much time during the day
we're gonna fix that in this video so
i'm constantly looking at how i can work
smarter i'm constantly looking at how i
can
hack myself hack my schedule to get more
done be more productive be more
efficient and work towards
building a life that i want to continue
to build this week is actually a great
example i've made a change in my
calendar
this week where i've always done
different things on different days
where you know monday is my mentoring
day and tuesday is my youtube day and
wednesday's my project day and thursday
is my
interview public facing day and friday
is my ceo day and saturday is my fun day
and sunday is my family been day right
and that's been
that's what happens every day as long as
i'm here in toronto and not you know
speaking or on tour somewhere
i made a shift where i was reading an
article over the weekend talking about
how some people are better in the
morning at being
in research mode in in intellectual mode
in planning mode and better in the
afternoon
at more creative mode uh
talking to people mode and i resonated
with that
even when i make these videos i've
shifted over the past couple weeks
to making my videos in the afternoon i
find when i make my videos in the
afternoon
i have more energy it's more fun i look
forward to it more
and when i make a video in the morning i
have to i have to force myself to bring
the energy more so in the morning i'm
less energetic
i'm less outgoing i'm less willing to
talk to people
and i'll do it if i need to but i'd much
prefer doing in the afternoon
and so now i'm applying that across all
of my days as much as possible
so in the morning chunk i'm spending my
time doing
planning and researching and
intellectual and data gathering and
processing
and in the afternoon is when i'm
spending my time doing instagram lives
and making videos and meetings and
talking to people and mentoring and that
kind of stuff and so
it's a test it's an experiment that i'm
going through right now and so far
i'm kind of liking it i don't know if
i'm going to make it prescriptive yet
and if i'm going to apply to everything
yet but so far i'm really liking it and
i think that's constantly the hack
because
hard work is important you have to work
hard
hard work though is just your ticket in
it's not enough just to work hard
there's lots of people who work hard but
then don't accomplish anything who don't
ever get their goals or dreams there's
people who just work smart
and and that's not the ticket either
right just working smart is not enough
either
it's that combination of working really
hard but working on the right things
that move your business forward so how
can you identify those right things how
can you make sure that you're working
both hard and smart
i've got a three-step process that i
follow that i'm going to share with you
in this video
step number one is make sure your
actions map to your ambitions your
actions need to map to your ambitions
so you look at your calendar you look at
where you're spending your time on a
macro on a whole like step above look at
where you're going to be spending time
in the next month
you say you want this you say you want
to be here you say you want this side of
life and this kind of business right
you say you want these things amazing i
love it that's inspiring
and and gives you hope and energy and
motivation great now
are you doing the actions to help get
you there where in your calendar right
on a monthly or weekly basis where are
you spending the time if you looked at
your calendar from above
where are you actually spending your
time to make that stuff happen
if there's no spot in your calendar then
chances are you're spending too much
time
on little things they're still important
to move things forward but they're
little
they're little for what you should be
doing and you'll never
end up building the life and business
that you want next year you'll be in the
same spot that you are right now because
you spent your time overwhelmed by
little things and never moving any of
the big things that you want
out of life forward so your actions have
to map to your ambitions
these are your ambitions show me your
calendar where that's actually happening
step number two is schedule for success
so now we've got a big picture of our
calendar now narrowed down on a weekly
basis
look at what you're gonna do from sunday
to sunday what days are you gonna be
doing what projects on
so i have my calendar where i do
different things on different days so
today's a tuesday i'm recording all my
youtube videos
on a tuesday that is an action that maps
my ambition right so back to step one
i wanna i wanna build my impact right i
wanna touch the world i wanna sell the
world's biggest problem
i think youtube is the best way to do
that right that's my ambition great
show me your calendar where you're
actually spending time doing it and how
do you schedule for success the second
part
well every tuesday i spend a whole day
on my youtube channel in the morning i'm
working now on my strategy my research
my data my analytics and in the
afternoon i'm making videos for you guys
right my actions are mapping to my
ambitions and it's in my weekly calendar
because otherwise i could want to be a
youtuber and have a big impact but if
i'm not making videos it's never going
to happen
so similarly plan it down like make it
nitty gritty
if you can block off an entire day for
something amazing if you can't do that
yet then block off
chunks block off a three-hour chunk to
work on your project block of an hour
chunk every week to work on your project
if you're consistently working on your
ideas on your ambitions
they are more likely going to happen but
if you never work on them
guess what it's never going to happen
and it just remains an idea in your head
so make a weekly calendar for yourself
from sunday to sunday
where are you going to spend your time
what are the big projects that need to
happen and then block off those times
and protect them and nobody's allowed to
get in the way of those things happening
because that's your life right there
those are your dreams right there that
you need to protect and safeguard
and set number three is pay attention to
your energy so this is what i look at on
almost daily basis
paying attention to your energy it's one
of the reasons why i shifted my schedule
so that in the morning i'm doing the
analytical work and in the
afternoons i'm doing the more creative
outgoing work
because my energy is a little bit
different and so you can look at your
energy
across projects if you're looking at
this project like i wanna
i wanna be a big youtuber and have a big
impact awesome but ah i don't wanna make
videos
like maybe you need to switch your goals
right so look at the things that you
wanna do
and what are the ones that actually give
you energy when i'm making videos after
i'm done making
i have more energy than when i came in
this gives me energy as much as i'm
i'm still afraid to do it i'm still
nervous you're not going to like it i'm
afraid of disappointment it's my number
one fear
and every every time i get in front of
the camera make videos it's another
chance to
potentially you know disappoint somebody
and that kills me but by the end of it
i'm always feeling
better i have energies like that was
amazing you know this is gonna this is
gonna help somebody let's go
so that should be your work right not
everything there's
there's tons of stuff you have to do on
a regular basis in the business
that you don't love that that that sucks
you dry
right but hopefully those are not
recurring things right those are one-off
things
the recurring stuff should be the ones
that give you energy that lift you up
that make you feel like this is worth it
and you want to keep going
pay attention to your energy daily
i don't think you need to beat the stun
up to have success
what matters is that you're productive
that you get results
that you stop wasting time too many
people default to thinking that if they
just wake up an hour earlier they're
going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
gonna be more productive
in a 17-hour day when you have less
sleep so this is a
interesting message in timing for me
right now because i
i love beating the sun up i love it i
love
working i like my default state if nina
is
off on a friday night with her friends
or something 80 chance i'm working i
love it i look forward to it
when i go close my eyes i can't wait for
it to be the next day like i'm pumped to
go off and do the work
i recently did a sleep study and my
doctor was concerned i wasn't getting
enough quality sleep so i went to go do
a sleep study
and the doctor after going through the
results uh told me that i need to be
sleeping eight and a half hours to nine
hours a night
and it and it like super disappointed me
eight and a half hours to nine hours are
you kidding me i i'm trying to go from
i was trying to go from eight to seven i
was waking up after eight hours sleep
and and feeling still a little bit tired
and so that's why my doctor recommended
even going to the sleep study
and i'm trying to figure out how do i
hack it to get down to seven and still
be fully functional not
not be you know lazy and slow and not
having my cognition
and uh yeah he said i need to be
sleeping eight and a half to nine hours
a night
he said is that is that normal like are
you not worried
like no as long as you're under 10 it's
normal people range from six to ten and
they're totally fine like this
sucks i mean i'm not happy about it i'm
still looking at how can i hack my sleep
more
and we've tried a lot i have the chili
pad we've got
you know meditation before sleeping i'm
lying on the bed of
nails with the thing behind me the
pillow the nail pillow
uh no you know phones or computers
x amount of time before going to bed red
light filters on everything red lights
no lights at all in the place right like
just these real red lights
going around after sunrise after sunset
lots of it
cool down the temperature i don't know
all of it don't eat past eight o'clock
no caffeine past two o'clock all of it
i'm doing all of that stuff all of it
right plus probably a lot more stuff
i've i've studied and hacked away
i still believe there's a lot more
hacking i still want to get it from nine
to seven
but but if i'm at nine and i need nine i
think you should get nine i'm at the
point now where if i wake up and the sun
is still
uh not up i stay in bed and and that's
actually
uh boosting of confidence is like okay
so i wake up and sun
hasn't come up yet okay this is hard
this is difficult it's difficult for me
to not get out of bed
i'm going to stay in bed just because
now i'm i'm a i'm a weird duck
so maybe this works for you maybe it
doesn't but i was having a great
conversation with
jeremy who's on my team who i've
invested in his business he's helping
companies scale their youtube channels
and he was going through the same thing
where he was feeling a little tired in
the afternoon
he wanted to nap on some afternoons and
that's never been me so dude you need to
just try waking up without an alarm
and he normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something um
so just wake up without an alarm and see
how it goes and he ended up sleeping for
nine hours
and hated hating himself for doing it
it's like dude maybe you need nine hours
like much more important than that extra
hour or two is what are you doing during
the day
if if you're losing energy during the
day and you want to nap every afternoon
you're not being productive like there's
no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win
i think everybody should get a sleep
test i think it's a brutal experience
you don't you barely sleep right when
you're there you got stuff up your nose
and a million sensors all over you
but to know how much sleep you actually
need and making sure that you're
productive
during the time that you are awake
that's the most important thing that you
are productive
during the time that you are awake is
way more important than if you wake up
before the sun gets up
okay so how can you do it i'm going to
give you a three-step process that i
think will help
step number one is fix your calendar fix
your calendar you got to make sure that
you're productive make sure your actions
map to your admissions the reason why
so many people say wake up early is
because your evening hours for many
people are not productive
because when you wake up you're more
likely to be productive
and you're going to you're going to do
your work you're getting your morning
routine you're going to feel like you
got a kick start on the day you're gonna
go off and start the question
where if you're staying up late at night
you're gonna find yourself playing games
or watching netflix you're doing things
that aren't productive right
like waking hours make sure you're
productive
put it in your calendar you're waking up
around this time right
how are you going to spend your morning
routine what does that look like and
then what are you going to do
and mapping it out so that when you can
step above your calendar and look at the
week and the month that's ahead you say
if i did these things that's in my
calendar
i'm going to be more successful i'm
gonna be closing in on my goals right
your actions map to your ambitions
so you create your calendar and then you
go and live it
and then you go and do it the most
important thing again isn't
making sure you're up before the sun
it's making sure that you're doing the
things that you said you were going to
do and the things that you said you were
going to do are going to lead you to
accomplishing the success that you want
to have
you have to be more productive and fix
your calendar step number two is
understand how much sleep you actually
need
right i i've heard it i guess before but
i didn't really buy it until i went and
did the sleep study
and again i'm still trying to hack it i
still believe i can get it lower
even if i go from nine to eight that's
amazing
but i have to be fully refreshed i have
to be ready to start my day and so
understand how much sleep you need right
here's a challenge
for tomorrow don't set an alarm and see
what time you wake up
and if and you sleep an extra hour and
you feel
more refreshed like you're probably
living in a massive sleep deficit
for you and so maybe you need seven
hours or maybe you need eight hours or
maybe you need nine hours
and if you need a lot more than that
then maybe you know there's a problem
you gotta go get it fixed
i was hoping that he could give me uh
like if i had sleep apnea amazing
my problem is sleep apnea awesome give
me the machine i'll sleep with every
night i'll sleep seven hours and i'll go
and crush it like no you don't have
sleep apnea
you don't you don't have any
deficiencies i did a bunch of blood
tests no deficiencies there's nothing
actually wrong with you you just need
nine hours sleep it just tears me apart
but you have to figure out how much
sleep you need because again sacrificing
one hour of sleep
and being tired all day is not going to
make you more productive
understand how much sleep you need and
then factor that into your calendar
factor that into your life so you can be
happy
you can be fulfilled you can have energy
and you can go and crush your goals
and then step number three is work to
your rhythm some people work better at
night than they do during the day
right again as i said earlier the reason
why so many people advocate for a
morning start
is because at night most people aren't
productive at night you're losing time
at night you're watching netflix and
playing games and doing things that
aren't in supportive of your mission
right
listen to grant though he goes to sleep
at nine gregor don't go to sleep at nine
and he wakes up before the sun comes up
he's getting enough
sleep to do it right but your best
productivity might be
at nine like maybe you don't even turn
on until nine maybe you should be
working
from nine until four in the morning
right
work to your style because if you try to
be somebody else and you try to work to
a different style that's not suited for
you you're not gonna win
it's more difficult if you're working
from nine you know p.m to four a.m
how many hours is that 10 11 12 that's
seven hours
right if you're working from nine to
five the other way
uh that's gonna be hard to do meetings
it's gonna be hard to have team calls
it's gonna be hard to
uh scale up your business right it'll be
difficult because most people don't
wanna work
for a midnight meeting with you but if
that's where you are your most creative
and that's where you
get the most productivity out of you
then you need to factor that in
if you're more of an night owl and
you're going to work every night you're
going to move forward on your ambitions
every night then don't beat yourself up
because you didn't get up before the sun
came out
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there